[Musica]
[Applauso]
qualche anno fa durante le cose ai miei
studi trovai una citazione di un certo
appeal promo un compositore e teorico
molto importante per la storia della
musica
la citazione è la seguente la musica è
una scienza che deve avere delle regole
certe
queste devono essere estratte da un
principio evidente questo principio può
essere conosciuto non può essere
conosciuto senza vento della matematica
e allora mi posi un interrogativo
possiamo considerare la musica veramente
una scienza ed eventualmente annoverarla
poi tra le scienze formali addirittura
le scienze empiriche il primo approccio
di carattere scientifico alla musica
risale a circa 2600 anni fa con pitagora
che con i suoi esperimenti di carattere
geometrico matematico riuscì a
determinare dei i rapporti esistenti tra
le consonanze ora per i presenti in sala
che non sapessero cosa cosa sia una
consonanza che non avessero
dimestichezza con il linguaggio musicale
diremo che detta in soldoni una
consonanza una torta di gradevolezza
uditiva chi prendete la sonora tra i
suoni presi in esame in particolar modo
scoprite la corda emette un suono questo
mese aveva già ma che la metà esatta di
una corda e mette lo stesso suono ma
all'ottava superiore quindi piovuto
perché i due terzi e mettono la quinta e
che i tre quarti la quarta quinta e
quarta sono intervalli consonanti non è
non è importante capire bene questo
quanto quanto fosse importante per
pitagora avere utilizzati i numeri 1 2 3
4 perché si rifacevano al concetto di
tetraktis è utile sapere che per
fidavano e quindi per i pitagorici poi
se la realtà sensibile e decifrabile
sulla base di relazioni matematiche
intrinseche e allora anche la musica
potrà esserlo perché facente parte della
sfera nazionale
infatti per pitagora i rapporti armonici
era una sorta di riflesso del di un
armonia cosmica che non l'uomo non
poteva avvertire perché nella se fatto
da molto tempo però c'era addirittura
più di duemila anni dopo keplero riuscì
a determinate degli analoghi smi tra i
rapporti intervallare e alcuni rapporti
tra il le velocità angolare al perielio
e all'atelier di qualche orbita
planetarie e quindi nonostante questa
affascinante questa idea affascinante la
teoria di pitagora presentato qualche
lacuna soprattutto dal punto di vista
pratico lacuna che a cui si cercò di
avviare poi durante la storia mi viene
in mente zarlino che cerco di allargare
i concerti tetraktis al senario quindi
non più i numeri da 1 a 4 ma da 1 a 6
ma non si riuscì praticamente a
soddisfare le esigenze pratiche e quindi
a trionfo di una concezione più aristos
è mica che pitagorica si decise di
dividere l'ottava in parti uguali e
quindi l'esigenza pratica supera in
questo caso le concezioni matematico
filosofiche parlando di numeri e musica
non possiamo esimerci dal parlare di
johann sebastian bach e fu uno dei
compositori più grandi e straordinari
della musica la visione della vita era
in e di conseguenza anche della sua
musica era influenzata fortemente la da
un aspetto teocentrico e simbolista
motivo per il quale si trovano nelle sue
opere dei rimandi espressamente
teologici a volte sotto forma di cam
atria che era una tecnica cabalistica
ebraica del di accostamento lettera
numero una volta con dei veri a volte
con dei veri e propri rapporti
geometrici ad esempio il gloria della
messa in si minore e ha sostanzialmente
formato da due sezioni la prima sezione
costa di 64 battute della seconda di 36
per un totale di 100 battute e con le
dovute radici quadrate sia ci hanno dei
dati assimilabile a un perfetto teorema
di pitagora
che bach lo facesse apposta meno non lo
sappiamo però è molto affascinante
a parte questo si trova la presenza di
proporzioni auree
ora per chi non sapesse cosa fosse la
sezione è ora proverò a spiegarlo senza
scendere in dettagli tecnici che
comunque sulle rebbero le mie competenze
per sezionare possiamo dire che è una
porzione di una grandezza quantificabile
grosso modo a meno di due terzi del
totale quindi sia quella proporzione lì
per cui il la parte piccola sta a quella
grande come quella grande sta all'intero
e rapportandolo poi al rettangolo aureo
una con si fa più interessante perché
poi può essere la matrice della
costruzione di una spirale logaritmica
ma come fecero i compositori a inserire
la sezione aurea all'interno del di
alcuni brani consideriamo che il numero
aureo e irrazionale
perciò nessuna frazione po determinarlo
precisamente ci sono sempre delle
approssimazioni entra in scena quasi di
fibonacci una serie matematica cioè
numerica che ha delle caratteristiche
ben precise
la prima è che ogni numero equivalente
alla somma dei primi due lei dei numeri
immediatamente precedenti è la seconda
il secondo aspetto è che tre numeri
consecutivi presi a caso l'inter nella
serie formano dei legami di proporzioni
auree spillo europee nazionali come
possiamo vedere più si va avanti nella
serie di banali per grandezze più ci si
avvicina al valore reale e quindi un
esempio è dubbio sì non solo lui
tantissimi altri compositori ma giusto
per farvi capire nel preludio per
pianoforte la cattedrale anglo tijd e
più si dà una prima sezione i 68 battute
una seconda di 21 per un totale di 89 ma
non ci interessa questo in quanto al 68
battute sono alla velocità del doppio
del tempo rispetto alle seconde 21 e
perciò vengono percepite le orecchie
come 34 è quinto a 421 per un totale di
55 sia una proporzione avere vero
ora io vorrei citare un altro
compositore ci sono
ce ne sono tanti in realtà linee mette
bartok o qualsiasi altro nel ventesimo
secolo
ma vorrei citare gli anni schena kiss si
è probabilmente nessuno di voi conosce è
un compositore un po atipico perché
prima di essere musicista era un
ingegnere lavorava da architetto nel suo
studio di parigi di le corbusier per chi
non sa essere così è uno degli
architetti forse più formose del
ventesimo secolo
perché xenakis la sua opera d'esordio fu
la prima opera musicale storicamente
composta solo esclusivamente da formule
matematiche un po difficile da spiegare
così però immaginate che lui a tavolino
matematicamente la compose e non solo
formule matematiche ma sezione aurea
come utilizzando il modulo di le
corbusier il motore un sistema di
codifica delle proporzioni auree per
l'utilizzo delle stesse in architettura
e questo pre si chiama metastases ed è
un'opera per orchestra un altro perché
vi farò vedere è pittura claire questo è
un grafico una porzione uno squarcio di
pisa pract che precede poi la
trascrizione in notazione musicale
probabilmente non immagine legge che
questo sia un embrione di partitura
verrotti e questo brano e particolare ci
interessa tanto perché è composto
esclusivamente col calcolo delle
probabilità infatti xenakis introduce
all'interno del della teoria del
processo compositivo il calcolo delle
probabilità e quindi addirittura
assimila teoricamente la teoria ci
critica dei gas
la legge di maxwell e le catene di marco
fa e quant'altro anche lui quindi di
concezione pitagorica assume il numero
come veicolo d'ordine
per la materia caotica musicale ovvero
per la massa sonora quindi per
raggiungere poi la determinazione
quindi è vero effettivamente io tutti
questi esempi anzi questi pochi esempi
li ho fatti per farvi capire che si è
stata influenzata la musica dal punto di
vista scientifico quantomeno matematico
ma a livello di approccio più che altro
per noi io personalmente non sento
l'esigenza di trovare una spiegazione
iper nazionale altre novero musica mi
può interessare le ricerche in ambito
fisico acustico una neuro scientifico
però dubito fortemente che il genio
artistico musicale di bach soprattutto
che ne so bene variazioni goldberg sia
assimilabile a un concetto di procedura
architettonica riconducibile poi è
riducibile soprattutto a soli numeri e
quindi vi voglio lasciare con una
citazione del ciclo tedesco è che brecht
che percorre un po quello che penso io o
meglio io percorro quello che pensa lui
e volevo citare anche un mio insegnante
che ci suggerisce che la musica non
necessita di essere spiegata con
nient'altro e non sia la musica stessa
grazie
[Applauso]